who had jacob congratulations you've
made it into the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forges where you will
recreate an iconic weapon from history
are you ready to see what that weapon is
oh yes absolutely right that weapon is
the jumanji yari
originating in the 1500s the jumanji
yari was carried by japanese soldiers
known as the ashigaru these peasant foot
soldiers relied on the long-shafted
spear for its reach and versatility and
combat using the weapon's double-edged
crossbars to disarm and pull mounted
samurai from their horses ashi gauru
could then employ the razor sharp
central blade to fatally skewer the
fallen enemy and all from a comfortable
distance today video game enthusiasts
can unleash the jumanji yari's
devastating capabilities in the game
shadow fight 2. good luck we'll see you
in five days
my name is jason gayton i'm 19 years old
i've been throwing eyes for 10 to 11
years or so and i've started blade
smithing because every knife i bought
kept breaking so i'm like screw it i can
do a better job i don't have a power
hammer i don't have a press or anything
like that my home forge i'll tell you
back i do have a power hammer
there's a hammer and there's the power
that is definitely getting my nerves
my forge has a few limitations one being
that my opening is
exactly eight inches wide i stick in
there just the right way the heat treat
on this weapon is extremely tough
because it won't fit in my forge
so far my main blade is getting a lot
harder than my two arms
can't let it get too hot so i can't let
it be too cold
shoot
got a wharf in one of my blades of
course
crap
my whole blade warped i still have to
hit for this thing again
i ain't gonna take the risk of trying to
straighten it too cold to snap it
there we go
that's what i like to say
i want this handle to stand out a little
bit because it's the biggest piece on
this weapon i'm gonna take my torch and
i'm gonna burn it i really like the way
it brings out the grain of the wood
i love the colder
the wood grain showing awesome pretty
happy with it i'm trying to think of
different detail work to put in this to
really make my piece stand out over
fujad so i decided to write forged in
fire in japanese
right here never wrote in japanese
before so this should be fun
[Music]
my name is buetta cowie people that know
me joke about how i can heat treat with
a cup of french fry oil and a bic
lighter and i think i'm really gonna be
able to bring it
traditionally a trident yari is forged
from one piece
i've taken a different approach where
it's going to be two pieces the blade of
the yari is going easily and i'm just
sailing through that part
i know i have a good heat treat on the
first blade
and the second blade look at that i have
quench the blade and i can start working
on the handle this rake company makes
their poles out of ash i don't have to
do a lot of finish work sanding work
which saves me
time that is some rake
my only hope
is that
my yard is half as strong as his rake
[Laughter]
wow i'm 11 inches short
this isn't gonna work
up to this point everything's gone too
well
and i'm snatching defeat from the jaws
of victory because of a stick i have
only one option left created steel
sleeve to extend the handle so it meets
all the parameters
i hope it's strong enough to do the job
what i've made is beautiful work that
may stand the test of time long beyond
the years that i'm on the earth
i hope the judges like it as much as i
do because i think it's some of the best
work i've ever done
bladesmiths welcome back to the forge up
first the kill test doug
i saw doug had an injury
i'm like well is he still gonna test it
the yari with its long handle and
multi-pronged spear
makes it a trifecta of points and edges
in a deadly weapon to see what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do i will
take your yari and deliver multiple
slashes thrust on this big carcass
quad you're up first you ready oh i'm
ready you can see that i'm still
recovering from an injury and i'm one
arm short
but
to have the pleasure of doing the kill
test i'd like to bring back one of my
students the marquette collie
i feel really good going into weapons
testing i think if the yari's using the
ways that i've read about how it was
used i know that i'm just gonna mince
that thing with my yari
oh
jesus
all right let's talk about your yachting
here we felt that it had very good
balance to it that on the initial slash
right here it dug in into flesh then it
hit the spine the transference of energy
hit a weak spot into your handle over
here
but it still had a secondary cut all the
way through
i would consider your blade
a kill
thank you
[ __ ] your weapons suffered a
catastrophic failure now that's bad
however you're not out of this
competition yet jacob
your yari still must perform in this
kill test let's see what happens
[Applause]
all right jacob let's talk about your
yachty in the initial swing
instead of being able to cut cleanly
with this part to cut through
this got in the way with the angle that
it had but let's talk about these
particular blades they are sharp enough
to penetrate into the pig carcass the
thrust is really devastating and very
deep into that
your handle construction
it stayed true no issues at all
overall your weapon will kill thank you
sir
my yari held up and i'm just
thank you
well fouad the blades of your yari were
beautifully constructed
the overall weapon was very elegant
however your shaft broke in our first
test and we cannot move forward in this
competition because that is a
catastrophic weapon failure
and i have to ask you to please leave
the forge
i was really confident going into the
competition and i felt like my yari was
gonna really perform a lot better than
jacob's and it's just pure irony all the
way down
jacob you are the forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
how do you feel right now i feel amazing
i came here to prove that i can actually
come out here at 19 and compete with
serious knife makers thank you sir
really i would have liked to beat fouad
in a different way but i'm the fortune
fire champion ten thousand dollars
it's awesome
you